foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell host of
the entree leadership podcast and
co-host of smart money happy hour joined
by my good friend Dr John deloney
best-selling author and host of the Dr
John baloney show and we are enthused to
take your call today America at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
your money boundaries mental health
seasonal affective disorder John I've
got oh I've got all kinds of terms today
and you've got all kinds of ailments and
issues it's fantastic and that's why
you're here to help me and to help all
of us and so it's a free call Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and we're kicking it off with our friend
Nick in Cleveland Ohio Nick welcome to
the show
thanks guys
um
so a little bit about my situation
um I have about 44 000 in student loan
debt
um and I'm currently in the the Army
National Guard
um which my contract is ending here next
month
and if I extend for another six years
um they'll pay off about 15 of that
student loan debt uh per year I think
over the course of the next
six years of which I think it's taxable
income and just want to get your
thoughts on do you think it's worth it
to extend
um to get the debt paid off or
try and pay that off with my personal or
full-time job
what is your full-time job
uh I do it auditing
and what does that pay
um I think about 105. oh sweet well
making 105 I mean is it taking a lot of
your time are you passionate about the
the National Guard stuff or would you
rather just lean into your full-time job
I I want to lean into my full-time job
but but at the same time you know I'm
going to be getting married here
probably within the next year
um and I want to buy a house
um and use my savings towards you know a
payment on that down payment on that
house
um so you know I could pay them off
right now
um but I don't know if it's worth it or
not to stay in I'm not that passionate
about it but here's the deal Nick don't
don't absolutely do not
do not risk the lives of those service
men and women who will rely on you
in the times of great stress and great
fear and great need and in a stressful
response situation just because you have
a six-year plan to get your student
loans forgiven
yeah and and I feel like I'm doing it
just for the money yes
this is the the stakes are too high
for you to do something this important
in this
um this dangerous quite frankly just for
the money
one of my closest friends and colleagues
in the world she is um in the National
Guard she does amazing things but she is
she is fully in she's fully committed
um and it's taken a lot from her and
she's she is service oriented so she
gives it that way if she was in this
just for a like man some cool perks and
over the next dude you make too much
money pay your stupid student loans off
and get on with your life
you feel you sound paralyzed by
indecision across the board this isn't
about this job this isn't about do I pay
my student loans off I kind of want to
get married you just don't need to start
making some decisions and start walking
forward some way
I know I just feel like it's like this
weight on my shoulders as a lot of other
people do you know in the country and
it's just the thought of
like hey you know I'm paying this back
it's
I'd rather use that money towards
something else than it did you sign your
name on a piece of paper and you told
somebody whoever they may be if you help
me get through college I'll pay you back
yeah then pay him back
he makes six figures dude and on the
math side I mean they're paying six
grand for the first year that's 15 of
the 44. it's not worth it when you make
105 to wait six years to become debt
free instead of you taking control and
going I make over a hundred grand I'm
paying this thing off in the next 12 to
18 months
and that puts your future in your hands
because now we're getting a home a lot
sooner once we become debt free we're
going to build a fully funded emergency
fund of three to six months now we're
starting to save up for the down payment
and now this isn't a six-year plan this
could be a three or four year plan
so I think you you know what to do at
this point from uh it's from the heart
issue to the math issue you know what
you got to do
the question is are you going to go
about the business of doing it and
saying I'm done with this debt and I'm
going to handle it myself
okay and listen I can't tell you brother
how many people have called over the
last two and a half years three years
I've been sitting in this chair
waiting for the next student loan
forgiveness thing that was going to come
through
it's been yeah forbearance and a
forgiveness and it would say Well
they're they're delayed and now we
they're just going to go into this
forbearance with no just pay the stupid
things off
pay them off
quit waiting for somebody to come save
you man let's do it and the day you pay
your last loan off the day you write
that check and hit send
and they come out and they announce
whoever they happens to be we're
forgetting all student loans you'll be
able to sleep at night because you sign
your name on a piece of paper that said
I'll pay you back and you kept your word
to nobody if nobody else but just to you
and you will have proven yourself you're
a person of character move on with your
life
is that fair
yeah I think that's fair be Resolute man
Stand Tall throw your shoulders back put
your head up
I don't think it's worth the other
or the to the other people to stay in
for another six years when I'm not fully
invested I I let me put it this way I
wouldn't want you standing shoulder to
shoulder with me
if you were doing this for an extra 500
a month in student loan forgiveness
I would want somebody who was ready to
jump in front of a bullet for me because
I'm ready to jump in front of a bullet
for you and if that's not where you're
at no it's all good I'm not in the
service obviously
um
then yeah I think you've answered your
own question
okay all right cool I appreciate all the
advice you got it man yeah I think the
person who you trust the least right now
is you you just feel indecisive and I
would say take a take a hard step and
also say this George
um there are people I've worked in this
industry for almost two decades there
are people who
signed their name away to things they
had no idea what they're getting into
and there was entire swaths of people
that I think were targeted and tricked
so there's no shame to sit down and say
hey I need help right and
um that's a whole other conversation but
if you're sitting there making six
figures and you're thinking about trying
to take this somewhat risky side gig for
the six years and just pay them off for
God's sake yeah it's not worth the
golden handcuffs at that point when
there's really not that much those are
like yeah those are like uh copper maybe
no they're like pipe cleaner handcuffs
pipe cleaner oh my goodness you know
what I mean they're like not very not
very strong well all of this
conversation reminds me of our
documentary barred future which you were
featured in John because of your
experience in higher ed you brought some
really cool perspective to this whole
thing so I want to encourage anyone
who's in this world you've got student
loans you're thinking about taking them
on please go watch our documentary
borrowed future it's on YouTube it's
free go check it out it'll spark some
amazing conversations from Pair parents
to kids so we got more of the Ramsay
show coming up and it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we'll be right back
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsay trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show in case
it snuck up on your Christmas is next
weekend that is weird to say out loud oh
my goodness I was gonna make some fun
but it snuck up on me I was doing
something that just got real this is
next week next week yikes well if you're
still running around like crazy you're
trying to find that last minute gift
quit worrying we got you we always take
care of you we've got an awesome gift
for anyone in your life and the best
part it's something that will actually
change their life it's called the live
and give box and it comes with an entire
year of Financial Peace University a
copy of The Total Money Makeover and
baby steps millionaires all of that
stuff is worth over 180 bucks and for
today only that's right just today we
are offering the live and give box for
just 79.99 so there's someone in your
life who needs this you're probably
thinking about them right now they're
struggling with money they're stressed
they're anxious and you can give them
some hope and when you order the box
today we'll make sure it gets there by
Christmas so get the living gift box at
ramseysolutions.com box again that's
ramseysolutions.com b o x that's
exciting well there there's the rest
your Christmas shopping John it's done
I know what you're getting Sheila I have
to say if I might do that just just
because just a troll Sheila yep just to
be like hey check it out uh I thought
you were gonna gift her just all of your
your questions for humans the entire all
of the decks under the tree is she
actually uh when we're we took a road
trip and we actually edited them in the
car like I we did them together to see
and if she was like that's dumb then I
threw it out and if she started laughing
or started crying whatever I was like
that one's gonna stay in and so she's
been through hours of those cards she's
done I think she's good my kids on the
other hand they love it they're they're
all about it yeah that's fantastic kids
love that connection with their parents
so it's good so good all right let's go
back to the phones triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the number
to call you jump in we'll talk about
your life your money your mental health
your relationships you name it Andrew
joins us up next in Austin Texas Andrew
welcome to the show
thanks guys how are you all doing we're
doing great what's going on with you
uh not much man just looking for a
little bit of advice here um so I've
been listening to the show for a little
bit and I'm just trying to figure out
the best moves next like I've saved up
started some of the baby steps saved up
a thousand bucks you know and I'm really
just trying to get debt free at this
point I have a little bit of credit card
debt about 6 500 bucks and then around
seven thousand nine hundred ninety
dollars in student loan debt
um and I've got a uh a stock from a
previous company that you know company
that I worked for they had a stock
purchase program you get a discount
they'd buy the stock for you essentially
and it's done well for itself and I've
got about twelve thousand dollars in
that so I was thinking about selling
that stock and then using that money to
pay off the majority of my debt I'm just
trying to decide if that's the best idea
or if I sh if I should still hold the
stock but if I do pull the starter if I
do sell it should I put it towards my
credit card that has interest on it
right now and then the remainder towards
my student loan debt or vice versa so
that's kind of just my where my thought
process is right now I just can't decide
what the best move is I love it well
welcome to the club of weirdos who do
money differently and one of those
things is cashing out those stocks now
beware you want to work with the tax Pro
there's going to be a tax implication
here on the gains and so make sure you
have that set aside to pay Uncle Sam
when that time comes due but yes use the
rest of that towards your smallest
balance so if that's your credit card
regardless of interest rate we are
attacking the smallest debt first so
you're going to knock out the credit
card tomorrow and then most of the
student loans going to get knocked out
too do you have money saved in the bank
as well
uh yeah I've gotta let's see well I've
got about
two or three thousand just saved in the
bank and then I've got uh around thirty
six thousand and a 401k and about 8 000
in a Roth IRA okay I'm sorry I haven't
done terrible saving but I'm just trying
to knock out the debt so I can save more
yeah well definitely do not touch any
retirement accounts don't pull any money
out of that but these stocks sound like
they're outside of retirement correct
correct yeah they were just uh it was
just an offering from the company and an
additional benefit essentially that was
like you know I can save up for this
it'll be money pulled out of my paycheck
that I won't see I won't I won't miss it
and then hopefully it'll work out and
this stock has gone from at certain
times it was bought at around 120 a
share and now it's around 350 a share
I'm cashing out on the games because
three weeks from now you're gonna say
I'm gonna hold it just to see what
happens and then for some reason it
tanks and all of a sudden your debt free
date just got pushed out so we tell
anyone if you've got volatile things
like crypto single stocks and you've got
debt just cash it out man you can't beat
the feeling of debt freedom and you're
gonna get there so fast you're almost
there if you cash everything out of the
bank except for that thousand for your
starter emergency fund cash out the
stocks throw all of that on it you're
gonna be like pennies away from debt
freedom
yeah yeah and that's that's kind of
where my head was at and I was just like
yeah I just didn't know the best way to
to go about it um but yeah real close
and just want to be done with with the
credit card and student loan debt be
done never look back and cut up those
cars close the accounts you will not
miss it man I'm telling you right now I
love it all right let's move on to Waco
Texas this is like the Texas theme out
where John is here for it Deandrea is
calling in from Waco Deandrea welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call how you
doing
good I have a question for you guys
um so we are we just started Financial
Peace University
um me and my husband and we've we've got
over the the first baby step thousand
dollars saved up so um question is I'm a
travel nurse and
um we we make good money but um
sometimes it's not consistent uh
consistent compared to like your normal
like salary based job so our question is
should we add more to our emergency fund
just to make up those possibilities of
not having
um income coming in or should we just
fit to the plan
now Deandrea do you really think there's
a month where we're not going to need
nurses in today's society
so are you a good one
yeah
we need the good ones more
I'm sorry we need the good ones more
when's the last time you got laid off
for more than like a week and you found
yourself with one two or three months
with no work at all
um three weeks was the the most okay but
yeah and how'd you make it through the
three weeks
well at the time we had some
um but we put a lot of that towards that
and so
um doing the baby steps and so we're
trying to figure out if we should still
have
about a month we had about a monthly
okay how much debt do you have
total
um including our house about 200 what
about without the house just the
Consumer Debt
without the help
and what's the household income right
now
right now is about 140. okay
so this debt's going to get paid off in
the under two years
if you keep this up if you're intense
about it
and so the way I'm looking at it is if
something really did happen where one of
you was laid off you still have one
income and you'd go down to Bare Bones
expenses which means we're cutting
everything and you're probably going to
find some kind of work in the meantime
if that happened right
right and so there's never going to be
just months of zero dollars coming in
and you're also going to change the way
you're living your life if you're in a
storm mode and so if that does happen we
tell you hey pause all the baby steps
and stack up as much cash as possible
until life is back to normal
okay when do you find out
um because we get this call with some
regularity if you were to if you knew
that um like your travel assignment was
was running out how much notice do you
get
um
not much noticed so we start I start
looking for a job a month left from my
current contract and
um I I try to have one set in place a
week after my last contract in okay
but do you do you have 30 days notice or
60 days notice or five days notice
um
I guess 30 days okay like George is
saying that feels like enough time for
you and your husband to say whoa we're
cutting all the spigot completely off
and we're gonna throw that's when you
could take some money you'll make 140
Grand a year and then you know it's like
hey we're gonna save some money we're
not gonna pay anything on debt we're
gonna go into to store mode right now
um that I like that a lot more I think
you're terrified to have a thousand
dollar emergency fund that's what I
really think and I want you to use that
energy to get this thing these debt out
of your life for good don't get
comfortable comfortable is what got us
here thanks for the call this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined this hour by Dr John
deloney and it's time for one of our
favorite segments on the show because on
the debt free stage we've got Eric and
Amber joining us how are you guys oh
we're doing great how are you guys doing
there's the happy couple where are you
guys from We're from a small town right
across the river from Saint Paul
Minnesota I love it all right and tell
us how much debt did you pay off we paid
off seventy two thousand dollars in 19
months wow what was your range of income
during that time roughly 110 to 1 30
that range love it and what kind of debt
was this 72. because all kinds of things
um it was personal loans it was car
loans student loans
um 401k loan credit cards 401K yeah wow
that's like a terrible Dr Seuss book oh
my goodness I'm just collecting them out
of everything which one was really
bugging you which was the one that you
were like we got to get rid of this
thing credit cards are always just a
anchor around the neck but I think the
one I hated the most was my 401k loan
because it just kind of hid in the
background and just siphoned money off
every month and we didn't even realize
in fact when we first came up with our
number that second week of FPU we didn't
even see that one like I had to go like
wait a minute this thing that's just
been there since 2008 we need to knock
that out oh my goodness yeah that one's
like punching yourself in the face and
just robbing future Eric yes exactly
that's awesome we're so proud of you
guys well thank you so tell us uh what
do you do for a living I'm in public
relations and I'm an elementary special
ed teacher awesome well thank you for
that that's some incredible lines of
work right there so what happened 19
months ago that you guys said we're done
we're drawing the line of the sand we're
done with debt forever yeah absolutely
so I was sitting at the kitchen table
had my laptop up in front of me and got
an email from work saying that one of my
colleagues Karen and her husband to
Wayne Stone were leading the FPU class
so I yelled into the other room I'm like
hey Amber you want to do FPU and she's
like sure grew up in church know what
financial piece is that sounds like a
woman married to a PR guy who just knows
whatever I'm in for whatever and for the
reason whatever you say so so we signed
up and we were excited and we went
through the first two weeks of of the
class and it was awesome right like we
enjoyed the camaraderie and the talk and
we had that hard situation where we put
those numbers down on the card and said
okay this is what's in front of us and I
remember I was on a trip I traveled a
fair amount for work and I was sitting
in Minneapolis-St Paul Airport and
um it was a Sunday afternoon and I was
just running numbers through I went to
Ramsay's website and was doing the debt
snowball there and I went through you
know a couple of others online and I
remember texting Amber and I'm like dude
this might work like it stopped being
like a theory and I'm like every one of
them is saying 27 months we could have
the 72 000 worth of debt knocked out if
we budget and stick with it and um and
it ended up taking 19 months not 27. but
uh so what do you attribute that that
eight months of saving like was it just
intensity and addiction to the plan of
like what else could we do yep well we
we sold a pickup truck to pay off the
pickup truck to
um we had two old pickup trucks
um and then it just snowballed from
there budgeting watching every dollar
um God is good we're just so thankful
that's incredible what was what was your
favorite
um disagreement over those 19 months
because there's one that you're both
like whoa yeah you know I don't know
that we had one this is a combo but we
don't really fight that much like we
just grow you guys should write a
marriage
okay so I'm just gonna be straight up
with you guys yes the biggest battle
that we had wasn't with each other it
was with ourselves and it was after we
got done with baby step two because we
had gone through baby step two we were
right on the cusp just getting through
it and we had these two beater old cars
and then one nice one
um and on our daughter who's with us
who's our rock star she turned 16. so we
went from we had we had two cars break
down so we went from having three cars
for two people to one car for three
people and I'm gonna be honest for about
three days this just happened overnight
for about three days after baby step two
in baby step three were like
maybe we should get a little bit of a
bridge not alone I'm not going to say
the word loan but maybe we should get a
little bit of a bridge and she instantly
stopped sleeping our stomachs turned for
about three days we fought this internal
battle until we decided
Line in the Sand we are not those people
who are going to do dead anymore we will
not go back into debt you had a new
identity yeah exactly and uh so we buy
when so instead we uh rather than
getting her a nice all-wheel drive SUV
we wanted to get we bought her this
little um green Chevy Spark that we were
able to go and peel off these little wow
that's like nobody over 100. and it was
the most fun we've ever had I had a baby
blue 1988 Tercel easy hatchback very
similar except your car is nicer it's
just the modern version yes so there's
nothing but but but roads ahead of you
it's good for you good times that's
incredible well it sounds like she was a
part of this journey as well yeah what
was the the biggest sacrifice that you
guys are looking forward to kind of
having back in your life now that you're
debt free vacation yeah vacation is good
so so the one thing the one thing we
wanted to do was sitting there in that
airport in in Minneapolis-St Paul I said
if we can do this if we can get through
uh this journey said we should do that
big Disney Dream vacation you've always
wanted to do debt free and uh because I
travel a lot for work uh we were able to
rack up the Marriott and Delta points
and um credit card not on credit card
doing it the old-fashioned way getting
on airplanes and going to hotels but we
were able to uh to get our hotel at
Disney we were able to get
um airplane tickets for the three of us
plus two of them as friends and we so we
just had to cash flow the tickets and so
we had this great trip where we was able
to talk to a bunch of Disney employees
and tell them about how we're debt free
and and uh they celebrated us and it was
a lot of fun dude that's amazing that's
incredible we're so proud of you guys so
you guys did this stuff and I know
there's another Eric and Amber out there
who aren't on the same page yet and
maybe they just tuned into the show for
the first time what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is
go first um doing a budget is a big deal
having the same why is huge too so same
page with a plan changes everything it
really does man you guys are rock stars
well is Emma doing the debt-free screen
with us we gotta know she's our why and
our biggest supporter she's coming up to
do it all right you come on up Emma how
how old is she she is 16. a bona fide
adult and she got to watch Mom and Dad
sacrifice at a time where she can really
remember it for the rest of her life and
I I have a feeling she's gonna stay far
away from debt she is here's what I
learned she got to see you all sacrifice
and work through it and then she got to
see a real life family Temptation like
Hey we're thinking about this this isn't
us just playing around we actually need
another car because one car and three
drivers is insane and we need it and
we're still not going to do it and
you're going to drive a neon green
roller skate for a while and we're just
gonna all smile about it it's like Yoshi
with an engine exactly what happens it's
amazing I don't know what that means you
know John so how does it feel you're on
the other side how does it actually feel
to be dead free amazing it's there's so
much peace that goes along with it guys
like if I could just appeal to everybody
just do it man just get on a budget get
debt free because it makes such a
difference in your life it's so much fun
now to be on this side of the journey
and rather than than working to pay
somebody else we're working and seeing
our bank account grow and our emergency
fund grow and and just I just appeal to
those people out there who are on the
fence just do it please
the the amount of Peace we had the
moment we started the moment we jumped
in we didn't have to get to the end just
the moment we had we we got it under
control
it's a world of difference man I love to
hear it well we we have a parting gift
for you it's the live and give box that
includes Financial Peace University one
year of that Dave's best-selling books
The Total Money Makeover and baby steps
millionaires that is absolutely the next
chapter of your story and you can feel
free to give those away to start someone
else's Journey off and maybe you've now
sent that email to some colleagues and
go hey we're leading FPU you want to
join how cool is that all right let's
get to it the moment we've all been
waiting for it's Eric and Amber and Emma
from the Saint Paul Minnesota Area 72
thousand dollars paid off in 19 months
making 110 up to 130 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
we're dead free
[Music]
and The Crowd Goes wide you did it that
was not Minnesota nice that was
Minnesota aggressive and I like it I
came from here there's some tater tot
hot dish on the other side of this I
don't even know what that means John
you'll learn one day we'll get you there
but man I just love I mean their
happiness and joy is just contagious
like my face hurts from just smiling the
whole time but watching her watching 16
year old Emma smiling and crying and
being excited this is so cool this is
why we do it right this is what we do it
so parents if you're like I don't know
how to connect with my kid I don't know
just sacrifice and become debt free and
that Bond will form with you and that
here's the thing we don't want our kids
to be uncomfortable we don't want them
to say no and get upset we want to give
things to our kids and I get that
but you want to give your kid
um true Joy sign them up for us for an
adventure and you lead the way give them
purpose give them Adventure give them a
a light at the end of the tunnel and
that you get that kind of smile right
there that I'm looking at right here
that's what it's all about this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by Dr
John deloney you heard us in our last
segment with that debt-free scream
talking about that live and give box and
today only we've got a killer deal on it
79.99 to get the live and give box it
includes a whole year of Financial Peace
University The Total Money Makeover and
baby steps Millionaires and it's an
awesome gift for someone in your life to
show them that you care and that you
want to see them win with money in 2023.
so check that out at ramseysolutions.com
box all right George listen to this I'm
scared you should be scared for all of
all of us
parents file lawsuit this is an article
from foxbusiness.com
parents file lawsuit saying their kids
are addicted to fortnite
for those of you who don't know fortnite
is a video game
a video game
lawsuit's been filed in Canada by
parents who say their kids are addicted
to the video game fortnite they say that
their kids are so addicted they don't
take care of regular everyday hygiene
such as showering some kids are so
dependent on fortnite they've stopped
eating and sleeping according to BBC
News and reported by Insider
the court concludes this is a serious
issue to be argued supported by
sufficient and specific allegations as
to the existence of risks or even
dangers arising from the use of
fortnight
they're equating the the in the suit
they're equating this to the the makers
of the game to Tobacco manufacturers
right so you could replace fortnite with
cigarettes and read that article that
does it that's right so here's my
thought
um yeah
there's a lot of crazy in this Twitter
push back if I'm out of bounds here okay
there's no secret I'm pretty open about
my disdain for video games I would
rather instead of my kids playing
baseball on a video game I'd rather than
go outside and play baseball
with people that makes sense or maybe
just weather and a ball and like a stick
whatever
so I'm not a huge fan of video games I
also understand that they're fun and
there's some data saying that they're a
way for people to engage in Partridge
blah blah sure
where I struggle here is
you're the parents
you're the parents but it's more fun to
blame someone else John you're the
parents if your child is addicted to a
video game
smash the video game controller and
throw it in the fireplace rip all the
cords out but then they're gonna be mad
at me as the parent John that
wow that is called parenting that is
called setting boundaries
cut the cut the internet off but then I
can't look at my cut the internet off do
whatever you have to do if somebody you
love who is a dependent on your care is
an addict and unable to get these
services on their own but they'll just
do it on their phone smash their phones
get rid of all you're the parent the
cool thing about all these electronic
systems is they've got this uh and I
didn't know this until recently on the
side of them there's a button and it has
the letters o f f and you can just push
it and the whole thing I've never tried
that that's amazing what a life hacks
and what a life hack turn it off turn it
off turn it off this is different than
being told I think being told hey uh
cigarettes
are in fact they're not addictive at all
um they're not great for you right but
they do calm you down they do make you
feel a little better or whatever and
then they're being troves of data hiding
this
um we can't let anybody knows that hey
this is actually killing everybody
um it's different
than parents simply unable to say sorry
this is over and if this is a true true
addiction they need to get your kids the
mental health care that they need after
you've done the thing that a parent
should do which is Take Your Kids out of
danger
which in this case means using the off
button because you're the parents my
okay so am I am I crazy no I'm just
picturing what would happen if a parent
went and just turned the TV off while
the kids playing fortnite and the kid
just explodes in Rage
I just I want to be in the room for that
because it's entertaining to me
personally because I remember that as a
kid you know the parent comes on and
turns off the TV and you're playing the
video game it's like game on I mean you
go full adrenaline rage mode as the kid
well here's what one of the one of the
comp one of the company spokes people
said parents can receive playtime
reports that track the amount of time
their child plays each week and require
parental permission before purchases are
made and so the company stopped short of
saying hey you can turn the game off and
not let your kid play because they don't
want to do that that's an option because
they want to sell the game
but built into the game is this idea
that hey parents you will send you a
report of how much your kid is on right
maybe you're working three jobs
um you don't have to you're you're not
at home a lot we'll help you out
nah I don't want to look at that or or
hey we can go ahead and we'll give you a
specific passcode just for you parents
so your kids can't get on and buy a
bunch of stuff that makes sense nah
let's just look I'm suing you this is
equivalent John I I mean you devoured a
pack of gummies earlier and you love a
gummy bear it's like you suing Haribo
gummies for being like I'm addicted to
your gummy bears and it's your fault hey
I want Millions I actually covered this
on my show
I think there's something to that
um I think there there are addictive
elements to prepackaged foods and I
think that given enough time that data
will emerge it's there we know people
are addicted to sugar and humanity and
I got a choice to make
I looked at those gummy bears on the way
in and thought I'm gonna a few Don is
gonna feel not that great but right now
John is going to feel awesome and I
nailed him and you even looked at me and
said oh I'm your accountability partner
I thought we weren't doing even my wife
will occasionally put her hand on my arm
and be like just think about tomorrow
John just think about tomorrow right and
I I but I have a choice because I'm an
adult I'm not going to sue them for
tricking me it's a bag of Gummy snacks I
[ __ ] out of the gate can we all just
that's not probably wise but this
parents
at some point
either
it's and this is me being completely
serious at some point if you look at the
data on the Mental Health crisis we have
in our country with kids
I am
convinced beyond a shadow of a doubt
that the quote-unquote Mental Health
crisis is simply the bodies of our
children responding to they've been let
left completely alone they're isolated
they're not a part of their families
because Mom and Dad are super busy and
super stressed out and super raged out
and super stuck on the news and they're
sitting there swiping on their own
phones and these kids are completely
alone and they're locked in these
schools and they're
we've created this system for these kids
to exist and fortnite is their only way
out and
as parents at some point
either their bodies are going to revolt
or we are going to have to step up and
be actual parents which means saying no
and making a 14 year old mad at you or
turning the Box off or throwing it out
the Second Story window whatever you got
to do to keep your kids safe stop
blaming and start parenting yeah we
can't Outsource this to technology which
is kind of what's happened at this point
digital babysitters man yeah and I mean
I was part of the generation that grew
up we played video games but we also
went outside and still did stuff and my
parents loved me and I you know they
didn't have super strict you gotta but
they just raised me in such a way to go
hey maybe don't spend your entire day
glued to a screen either right that
can't be good for you I don't know that
we need studies to even prove that
it's a sad like study show it's like uh
I think I think you and I had this
conversation
um I was a part of a of a brain science
study a lot of questionnaires and yeah
yeah and they brought us in and gave us
like this six or seven or five things
whatever and I remember my grandmother
had literally told me six out of the
seven or seven I mean it was like go
outside spend time with people turn off
this Electronics it was like oh this
this is neuroscience I thought it's like
literally my grandmother told me that
and so anyway all that a lot of common
ground between common sense and
Neuroscience yes and hey I might let my
kids play video games this upcoming year
I've thought about it that's big right
it will be for a very very limited time
with supervision will you play with them
I feel like that's a key maybe I might
I'm more fun but I'm not going to cash
in my parental responsibilities just
because they're holding a controller and
they're transfixed on a screen I'm still
their dad whether they're holding a
video game controller or not parents you
are in control that's right as long as
you pay the bills as long as they're
under your roof you have a matter you
have a choice you can make good
conversation John appreciate it man that
puts this hour of the Ramsay show in the
books my thanks to all the folks in the
booth making the show happen today
Austin James and Zach and Andrew and so
many more and you America thank you so
much for listening we will be back with
you before you know it
foreign
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsay personality George
Campbell Join This Hour by Dr John
baloney and we are taking your calls
about life money relationships the
pursuit of happiness you name it triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number to call and by the way if
you are a long time listener of the show
or you've been listening for a day and
you love it we would so appreciate you
subscribing to the show wherever you're
listening follow leave a review and
share it with a friend we want to spread
the impact of the show and Inspire more
people to debt freedom to relational
Freedom you name it all it takes is a
subscribe a follow a share and that's
all free to you all right let's get to
the phones this hour uh Hari joins us in
Pensacola Florida to kick it off Carrie
welcome to the show
how you guys doing guys doing today
we're doing great how are you
how can we help
so I listen to you guys show
um frequently I stopped listening for a
while because I've been
um kind of listening to nothing in the
car but I need to hear that I am
thinking about like wanting to buy a
home that you like my lease is up in
March and I live in an apartment it's a
three-bedroom apartments pretty nice but
I pay mortgage rates for it but I just
don't feel like I'm in the position to
buy wine you know but like having the
20K in the bank perfect credit score All
That Jazz
so I just wanted some advice on that and
how to like get more money out of what
you're doing in life like if you don't
want to switch jobs but like
you kind of like you know grow your
money and get more out of your money
okay well number one I just want to
squash the fallacy and the myth that
that renting is a sin and that you
should always be a homeowner and that
mortgage your mortgage could be the same
as the rent and it just doesn't work
like that in reality there's so much
other things to think about when it
comes to being a homeowner and there's
so much more risk and there's so much
more that's on you instead of the
landlord and so I want to encourage you
that you don't need to go be a homeowner
tomorrow if you're not ready that's in
fact the worst thing you can do for your
financial future so let's talk about
where you're at today and how we can get
you to becoming a homeowner sooner what
what are you doing for work right now
I'm a vendor full-time and I'm also on
the side I'm a brain investor you're a
what on the side a brand ambassador a
brain Ambassador okay and what brand I
thought you said a brain okay brand
ambassador all right and what is your
income
about last year I made about 55 57 a
year okay I'm single so and that's often
my main job and then I have like four
three or four jobs and then I do my side
job wow so how many hours are you
working a week
I worked like seven days a week right
now I work like crazy but the good thing
is with my main job I can like make my
schedule and I kind of have flexibility
and so I I it's all in one I just you
know do my job and then I'll pick up
like gigs and events when I can and so
I'm a high paid summer low page it just
depends and then I work part-time at OHA
and then I do like some other stuff too
and what are you doing all this for
because it sounds like you're really
driven you're working really hard what
are you doing all this for what's the
end goal
so I can like get salary of sixty
thousand dollars a year okay because my
question is could you work 40 hours a
week at a full-time job making 60.
by the way the answer is yes that was
rhetorical the answer is yes yeah but I
still wouldn't stop doing side jobs I
don't want to ask my employer for more I
mean I love my job what I do I get paid
holidays I get 401K get to make my own
schedule I don't have to work weekends
so it's like when I'm done with work I
can pick up a second job you know and
you know go work and make money before
you hop in there like I just wanna I
wanna just press on that and then I'm
gonna let George talk to you about the
math here
the way you just described that was
incredible because you're trading a like
a a stress-free job I can pick I don't
have to work the weekends I can uh don't
work holidays I get a 401k great so I'm
gonna choose to make less money and have
a stressful full-time job
so that I've got enough room to go
hustle and grind on the weekends and in
the evening and make more money over
here
thereby luckily I don't have to work
nights now I just work weekends just
just
weekends so let me tell you if you're
gonna make sixty thousand dollars you're
gonna make seventy five thousand dollars
you're gonna make a hundred thousand
dollars here's what I'm hearing as
somebody who's hired a whole bunch of
people throughout my career
I want someone like you on my team
and depending on the job I would pay you
more than you're making right now
because I can see that you work really
hard and that you're committed and you
will get the job done
the only person who doesn't believe in
that equation right now is you
and so you're trading what feels like a
simple
low-stress day job for the privilege of
not working all of your weekends instead
of saying okay I want to go make 60 or
75 000 bucks
people who make 60 or 75 000 earn 60 or
75 000 they work hard they work really
hard and they put their time in and just
because they're making 65 or 75 000
doesn't mean that uh let me say this I'd
rather work the day before Christmas
once a year
then every weekend of the year
right and so you're making a trade
whether you thinks you are or not and I
want you to hear George and I say we
think you're worth more than you're
allowing yourself to be paid right now
okay okay so George that's not what you
called I just want to give you that
shout out okay before we run out of time
how much debt do you have
okay so my dad I it's probably like five
to ten thousand dollars it's really low
I'm paying all my college funds and just
like some credit cards and stuff so you
got credit cards and student loans
yeah and then my car I just bought a
2017 Infinity last year and my name and
everything and the engine went out on it
so I had to like do this whole thing and
get a new car and everything so right
now I'm just working on you know raising
that and getting that great credit score
get my expense account and have no no no
no no we're chasing the wrong things
Gary we want to run away from everything
culture has told you to do because it
got you to where you are today you did
everything culture told you to do didn't
you
uh-huh you worked hard you got your
credit score up you got the payments you
could afford side Hustle and here we are
today stressed feeling like we're not
making traction you're not closer to
home ownership than you were yesterday
and so here's what I want you to do
forget about the credit score because
it's only important if you're going to
take on more debt and when it comes to
the mortgage which is the one where you
go how am I going to get a house there's
a process called manual underwriting to
where if you don't have a credit score
you can do a no score loan through
manual underwriting I did it myself this
is not Theory this is not unicorn
mythical stuff this is stuff you can do
if you have a strong down payment so I
want you to get rid of all this debt do
you have any money in the bank
um right now at the end of the month I
only have like a thousand dollars in the
bank and that's the thing I mean I pay
all my bills myself and you know and you
know my you know when I'm as being a
single mom or I need help I'll you know
I'll get financial help but well we want
to give you one next step you can take
and that is Financial Peace University
watch all nine video lessons I'll
include every dollar with that our
budgeting tools so that you can start
mapping out a plan for every single one
of those dollars you're working so hard
for and put it to use by paying off this
debt building up a fully funded
emergency fund and then we can start
talking about saving up a down payment
and becoming a homeowner I'm also going
to give you paycheck to purpose and Ken
Coleman's get clear assessment so you
can find a new job one that will pay you
what you are worth the full kit and
caboodle right there all four of those
things hang on the line Austin's gonna
pick up we'll gift you with that to
Kickstart this new life
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney and we are taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five all about your life your money your
relationships boundaries mental health
you name it Dr John is a specialist in
that category John what kind of calls
are you getting on the Dr John deloney
show these days what's the what are the
topics is there a theme you're saying
what's everything from parenting to
marriage challenges this time of year
it's always family boundary boundary
issues and how do we do Christmas and
how do we do Thanksgiving and things
like that and then there's just the my
kids got ADHD or Autism and I don't know
what to do next and so it's it just runs
the gamut I love it well it's a great
show you're doing great work over there
really diving deep with callers long
form calls and people are loving it so
be sure to check that out if you enjoy
the Ramses show you will enjoy the Dr
John deloney show it's all on the Ramsay
Network or wherever you listen to
podcasts all right Caden joins us up
next in Columbus Ohio Kaden welcome to
the show
thank you for having me absolutely
what's going on with you
um so I was just wondering about some
practical next steps I could take
um I'm pretty young I'm 18 years old and
I've just had like hurdle after hurdle
and my financial uh life I guess
um I back in September my car was
totaled and then I'm not really getting
paid much on my job
um I feel like I could be making more
don't have any debt
um and I just bought a bike as a resale
investment and the engine is blown and
so all my money is wrapped up on that
I'm at like score one right now
like 100 bucks what are you making at
your current job
um 20.
why are you only making 20.
um that's minimum wage if that
um yeah so it it's just a little bit of
a complicated situation but I'm working
for a family-owned company it's a small
company we make a bunch of like um
aftermarkets parts for quads like
suspension a arms we used to make swing
arms we also make a roll cages bumper
strums and stuff like that is this
full-time I feel like it could be it is
full-time are you making any money
uh my take home is about 630 bucks and
you can't live on average yeah you need
to go find a new job yesterday I know
it's your family and I know that you're
getting they're telling you you get good
experience so one day this will all be
yours but you're not making enough money
man
what was that
you're not making enough money you got
to go find another job
do you not believe you can make more
elsewhere tomorrow
um
I I mean the reason why I'm still with
the company um it's a family-owned
company but not by my family
um and the reason why I'm still with the
company is because
um I believe that there would be
something better there and so I was
actually working a second job with my
family uh Donatos actually and but that
was too much because I was doing like
100 hour weeks and stuff like that but
yeah how old are you
18. what do you want to be doing at 22.
at 22.
um I would like to be married uh what do
you want to do career-wise
career right career-wise
um take welding so I'm actually I tell
you well on all these parts
did you go to trade school for that or
you just learn on the Fly
oh I went to trade school so why not get
a welding Dude full time
yeah all your licensures and everything
yeah I actually graduated top of the
class of Marion
so dude what are you doing man I've got
a buddy who's a welder and he laughs at
my paychecks like he's doing quite well
are there no welding jobs in your
community
uh not not immediately around they know
have you checked have you called every
welder in town and said hey I graduated
top of the class I'd love to work for
you or call your college back and say
Hey I want to talk to the Career
Services Group
um
what I'm hearing is a guy who Who had
who got punched in the face a few times
and now doesn't think he's worth
anything and is like well maybe
eventually something will happen like
you're you're just like a passive person
in the story of your life and I want you
to believe that you're a main character
and that you have some control and right
now it feels like you're just waiting
for the next big thing to happen
yeah so I think you need to take a big
step because you've lost the wind in
your sales man and that step is I'm
gonna go believing Kaden and go find
another job that pays me what I'm worth
so that I can get ahead financially part
of the reason you're calling in saying I
can't get ahead financially is because
you're barely making ends meet making
600 bucks a month
oh well it is 600 bucks a week but I
mean it's
2400 bucks a month yeah and you have no
debt and you're still not feeling like
you can have traction and so you need to
find something where you get paid double
or triple what you're making now uh so
that you can hit your financial goals
I'm sure you want to be a homeowner one
day right
um and you want to have a big pile of
money in the bank an emergency fund and
you have other goals things you want to
do I'll also tell you man you're not in
a position at 18. I know dude I I I have
Instagram too and George I don't know
how Tick Tock works but George shows me
to his how the tick tocks I know there's
18 and 19 year olds all over it talking
about bro this is your way to the you
got dude you got to stop buying projects
and flips and I'm gonna buy this bike
I'm gonna flip it for this dude
just take the boring route take the
boring smart route that has helped
millions and millions of people
build Financial Security man
and it just don't overthink it and don't
over but like George mentioned man you
want you're trying to be safe and I've
got this job and it's just cool and I
work a parent with my parents and it's
cool
but I'm just not getting anywhere well
then you got to change something you got
to change something and money only works
two ways you can make more of it you can
spend less of it that's about it in fact
that is it right and so if you're not
spending more then you got to earn more
so go go get it man Just Go Get It Go
Get It Go Get It Now We're cheering you
on man thanks for the call all right our
blinds.com question of the day is upon
us they're 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you miss measure you pick
the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more make sure to use the promo code
Ramsay to get the best deal all right
today's question comes from Mike in
Delaware Mike writes I have extremely
loving and gracious parents oh boy
my parents are offering to upgrade my
roof but I'm afraid of the strings that
may come with it later in my life why is
Mike why is Mike the reason for my
hesitation is my mother's loose tongue
wow she makes snide comments from time
to time which makes me not want her
assistance I don't need a new roof yet
but recognize I am very fortunate to
have parents that are in a position to
help me how should I go about this
should I accept a gift or keep my
nobility and save up for next summer
when I can pay for a roof on my own
I don't think taking a gift from your
parents is has anything to do with
nobility
I think that is your way of talking
yourself of giving yourself permission
to not be in business with your parents
and when you take money from them you
are in business with your parents and
your mom sounds like she
um
pays a fee
for permission to speak into your life
and you get to no longer do business
with her I would not George I wouldn't
take this money I would say hey thanks
nope I'm grown up I bought my own house
I'm gonna save up and pay for my own
roof by the way I don't even need one
right now you don't have to be ugly
about it you don't have to be rude about
it
um but you know you've dealt this your
whole life Mike your whole life you've
dealt with this Mom helps you out with
something and then she just has to
berate you about it man at some point
yeah I'm growing up I'm not taking their
money anymore I'm still gonna love them
still gonna go to lunch with them on
Sundays that's great I'm just not taking
your money anymore yeah I would listen
to that hesitation that you have that's
your gut that is wisdom and I think this
is just pure resentment down the road
one way or the other if you do take this
thing because you already uh are you're
not the spirit of this doesn't feel
right to you and I'm gonna listen to
that and say you know what I'm gonna get
myself in a position where I have the
money in the bank to cover the roof I'm
gonna say Mom Dad love you guys thank
you so much for offering uh but I got
this one and there's something symbolic
I mean maybe fixing the carpet or air
conditioner or something there's
something about the roof because there's
just always that line well I'm still
putting a roof over your head and
there's just something about it they're
literally putting a roof over your head
as an adult that gives me that gives me
the indigestions and the gases not quite
the hemorrhoids but it gives me the gas
and I I just like pay for it yourself
man pay for yourself I don't want the
strings attached I'm no puppet yep all
right thanks for the question Mike it's
a good one a lot especially with all the
boundary issues happening around the
holidays Now's the Time to stand your
ground and say no and do it lovingly but
do it firmly more of your calls coming
up triple eight eight two five five two
two five this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by Dr
John deloney and on the debt free stage
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions Phillip
and Bethany join us how are you guys
great how are you what a beautiful
couple where are you guys from uh Jasper
Indiana wonderful and you're here to do
the debt free scream how much did you
pay off uh right around 174 thousand
dollars whoa okay and how long did that
take uh it took us about four years and
10 months okay and what was the range of
income during that time
um starting out we were right around 95
000 and then when we ended uh we were
around 150 000. love it what do you guys
do for a living uh I'm a automotive
technician at a Chevrolet and Cadillac
dealership and I work at a local uh Bank
to us in the insurance department
awesome yeah well we're so glad you can
make it and celebrate with us what kind
of debt was the 174. uh just about
everything yeah we had some small credit
cards personal loans uh what else we had
a debt on a piece of property that we
hope to build a house on someday
we had um that felt so right to buy at
the time
it was the only one like it oh of course
yeah and this is this is for us in the
future you never get this opportunity
again exactly yeah this opportunity will
never come again right that's exactly
what we told ourselves and uh let's see
we owed
um my father-in-law her dad sixty four
thousand dollars
doesn't motivate you I don't know what
yeah dude you owed him money and you
were kissing his daughter man yeah he
likes holidays what was 64 000 for uh a
home remodel uh home Remodel and uh but
then we also paid that home off so we
paid our mortgage off
way to bury the lead there incredible
yeah hey I don't know man I think
there's something
I I haven't been on on the this year I
haven't been on this journey I can
imagine the check you wrote to your
father-in-law felt better than the one
you wrote to your mortgage company uh
yeah yeah I think you're right yeah when
we wrote him the last check because he
he was our he was our largest dead Okay
um other than our mortgage at the time
but he was the largest debt through baby
step two and when we wrote that check it
was pretty emotional yeah and and you
don't have to give him credit because he
did not harp on us I mean we owed him
money for for probably well over 12
months yeah over a year and um you know
he never brought it up never made it
awkward we just kept writing the checks
for as much as we could every month got
it taken care of and when we went to pay
our mortgage off we just went to the
bank and then we went home and like yeah
the grass and I made dinner so it was
like
yes
Dad you're weeping the whole way home
and you're hugging and then yeah yeah
wow yeah exactly and now uh Christmas
dinner is going to be a lot more
pleasant that's right yeah because
you're not in the back of your mind
going I know he's thinking about the
money we owe him right he's looking at
my new shirt and he's thinking he's like
you owe me money
yeah yeah fortunately yes neither one of
her parents ever brought it up wow how
long have you guys been married for 10
years you'll be 10 years wow so about
five years into marriage you guys are
going all right we collected enough uh
Monopoly debt here we gotta clean this
up what happened yeah
um well in July of 2016 in July 2016 so
we we bought a a fairly older home but
we lived in it for quite a while
um and then July 2016 we started with
some remodel plans and if you could
imagine how remodeling an old home goes
there was a lot of unforeseen costs
involved I told her that you know if
when my father-in-law who was doing all
the work on it if I had a dollar for
every time he said well I didn't plan on
this and we would have had that job paid
for it was all the money and he was the
which is why we owed him all the money
excellent wow so you know we were kind
of going through and we had some small
debts like I said credit card personal
loans but they were all manageable they
weren't really a problem and as we were
going through that remodel we didn't
really have any money so we just decided
we were going to refinance our house
whatever that meant that was somehow
gonna pay for all this this this work
that we were doing so we didn't really
understand that at all uh and then and
probably around October 2016 he handed
us a bill for 46 000 and we had about
five thousand dollars in their bank
account so we knew uh something was
gonna have to change and then I guess a
blessing is in January our church was
hosting Financial Peace University and
so we signed up and
and you guys had enough fire in your
belly going this was scary let's not
have this happen again yeah when he
handed you that bill did he know you
didn't have forty six thousand dollars
um I think he had a good idea we didn't
have 46 000 but you know we probably
hope we had more than five so that
somewhere in between I mean in your
defense like I've had work I've had
General Contractors out of my house this
year
we talked through what the final bill we
did an awful job of that oh it's just
like what about you guys I got you yeah
yeah we somehow thought five thousand
dollars that we had was gonna like yeah
I'll cover it yeah incredible oh my
goodness so what was the hardest part on
this journey because five about five
years that's a long time to be just
powering through this thing I think the
hardest thing was just like by the end
of it I was like ready to just like pay
the house off and I was like this is
taking so long like I just want it gone
I just want it done so I think just like
but I'm a very impatient person anyway
so I think that was the hardest part I
mean because both of us I think were
very like head down this is what we're
doing you know like this is the plan
we're sticking to the plan it was just
like
writing out that waiting period of
and it's another thing to add in the
mortgage to your to the debt too and go
you know I'll just keep going yes right
yeah yeah and I think the hardest part
for me was the part-time jobs yeah
part-time jobs that was the worst one
that you're like I will never go near
this one again uh we really did the same
thing we had a we had a part-time job
cleaning offices after hours it's like
that wasn't the bad part it was just
like such long days could we because we
would go there right after our normal
exhausted yeah and we would be at this
part-time job until nine o'clock and
then get home and you know have to do
all your normal like evening things and
so and they get up and just do it again
exactly
it's not what we wanted to do with our
time yeah but because we were in debt we
did this to ourselves we didn't get to
say what we did with our time we had to
go to work so what's it like when the
checks deposit now and you don't owe
anybody anything
um I don't know it's kind of crazy it's
we really are just like okay well what
do we do now I mean yeah
I mean it's a really I mean it's a good
feeling like just be like we literally
owe nobody any money like yep no one at
all no no
I wish y'all could I want you to go back
and watch us on YouTube because you're
smiling for so big yes yes so what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is because you guys did this
stuff I know there's another couple out
there who's like should we shouldn't we
what is the key to actually getting us
done
I think just like you have to remember
the feeling of like like for me whenever
we my we got this bill of that we
couldn't pay I was like literally so
scared and so afraid like and I feel
like you have to go back to that feeling
of like I didn't like that feeling at
all and you know I'm never like I don't
ever want to feel like that again so and
then
um yeah I think just being scared and
like how are we literally going to pay
this you know like you have to be tired
of being sick and tired yeah and you
know at the time at the start we were
making fairly decent money but somehow
we were eighty six thousand dollars in
Consumer Debt and and with an 88 000
mortgage at the same time and um so it
definitely takes a it takes a budget and
takes a lot of hard it takes a budget
and I mean it's not fun at all times and
now you're free yeah yeah we are free
yes well we're celebrating you guys uh
with the live and give box you'll go
home with that today it includes a year
Financial Peace University you can pass
that on or go back through it to stay
motivated a copy of The Total Money
Makeover and Dave's new us book baby
steps millionaires that's your next
chapter so so proud of you guys so glad
you could come celebrate with us you
ready to do this thing yeah yes yes all
right it's Phillip and Bethany from
Jasper Indiana
174 thousand dollars paid off house and
everything yes being weird living like
no one else in four years and 10 months
making 95 all the way up to 150 with
those side hustles crushing it count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one we're dead free
[Applause]
your weekends and evenings are once
again yours congratulations job well
done that is how it's done and it's
available for all of you listening out
there you can do this stuff you got to
be willing to make the right sacrifices
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney and it's crazy to say it out
loud but we're just a few weeks away
from 2023 it's a brand new year and I
can't think of a better way to start it
than investing in your relationships and
making some new friends while you're at
it and uh Dr John specializes in
Friendship it's uh it's on his resume
there dude I'm I'm actually just had a
conversation with my wife the other
night it's like man after being on the
road I'll I'll fall like I'm pretty
lonely guy right now and she said don't
you talk about that a lot and I was like
yeah I need to be really intentional
about friendships in the upcoming year
well it's a great time to ask you do you
want to hang out tonight
it's all good but really it it's hard to
make friends as an adult but it's not
impossible it starts with a simple
conversation and inviting your friends
uh over go out to your favorite
restaurant or pick up the uh one of the
questions for humans decks which are
just going bananas right now when you've
got different uh decks for friends girls
night guys night dating workplace
Christmas you name it and there's uh
second editions on some of these decks
yeah um we're notified by by the by the
printer they're out of paper
they just sold so many they're like they
can't do this bananas it's like nothing
anyone could have imagined you must be
exhausted at that warehouse just making
these things it's pretty wild well it's
fun uh each deck you know every car has
got a different kind of prompt a
question on it and they're fun they're
going to spark some great stories some
great laughs some deep conversation hey
here's the here's the friends second
edition uh here we go uh-oh
um this is assuming we're friends wind
This Is Us trying friendship out when
did you realize your parents had no idea
what they were doing
oh gosh they're probably listening to
this show right now so this scares me
let's oh wow so you're still under their
wing I see that yeah well mom's mom's a
big fan oh all right what's one song or
album that makes you super nostalgic oh
probably Coldplay's first album okay
with yellow on it why I think because it
was like you know that time when when
music was actually special you had to
like download it illegally from LimeWire
and you had to upload it to your iTunes
and then put it on the iPod and then you
just listen to it in your room that's
that's that album for me I thought that
album would be the one that you saw on
MTV and you thought I could get my pants
to be way tighter than that so much
tighter and uh what was it for you it
would have to be
that I remember you the song off the
skid row album it was the
um it's got one of the greatest guitar
solos of all time and Sebastian box say
it I just used to put it on repeat and I
would just listen to it and think if I
could ever get someone to love me this
much this much and I've been Tori
married 20 years and it's I'm still not
there yet no not there yet but man that
song I remember you on the Skid Row
Record oh my gosh you've gone wild uh
yeah that's wrong with that record
that's strong well there's there's many
more cards I mean we could just take the
whole show and do this but America needs
needs help John so if you want to check
these out uh connection doesn't have to
be awkward our friend Dr John makes it
easy with these decks they're great
conversation starters and you can pick
one up at ramseysolutions.com until they
can't print anymore because they've
apparently run out of card paper that's
right there you go and while you're
there we we mentioned this in the debt
free screen we've got this new live and
give box and today only we've marked it
down to 79.99 and part of the reason is
it's one of the last days you can get it
before in time for Christmas so go check
that out at ramsaysolutions.com box it
includes Financial Peace University
Total Money Makeover and Dave's new book
baby steps millionaires all for just 80
bucks that's a killer deal all right
let's go to the phones it's a free call
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five Erica is hanging out in
Indianapolis Erica welcome to the show
hello hey what's going on
while I was calling to hopefully get
some advice about
if there's any ideas on how to go from a
double income or fam my husband and I
and I had to resign from my medical
career about the end of 2020 due to a
chronic illness and which they've
finally diagnosed with Lyme disease so
sorry that's the worst it's a very hard
thing I don't know if in Indiana I know
it's a hard thing to get diagnosed with
but not a lot of doctors in the midwest
are from really
it's just very frustrating for me and I
feel so bad for my husband and my family
for having to just you know work with me
through that so I was hoping hoping to
lighten his load because he's had to
take on all financial responsibility
and be my caretaker so I just wanted to
run some things by you and see if you
had any thoughts or ideas
go for it
okay so basically my husband's a salary
job he's an international Logistics and
he's about 70 000 per year salary and I
was at about 40
000.
when I worked my whole life but now
that's gone well right before
I got ill and had to resign I ended up
getting my first financed what I call a
big girl car payment because I always
bought my own cars outright and never
had a car payment so it couldn't have
come really at a worse time for me to
you know buy a car but I am paying 450 a
month
and that is really really hurting us the
450 a month and you still drive 10 000
per month
yes I can still drive and we're actually
down to one car right now so
car is important what's your total debt
how much how much do you owe
on the car no totally just in general
what other debt do you have uh my
uh I have the car for 17. my husband had
some credit cards
listen listen listen listen you've
already started talking this way
throughout this call so
you and your husband are together y'all
are one
right he said for sickness 17 plus 10.
okay yes there's not his debt in your
debt there's not now I'm a burden
because he's got to take care of me he
gets the Supreme honor of loving you in
a time of need
yeah that's a nice way of putting out
there you're not a burden it's what he
signed up for this exact moment does is
it fun no does he wish you're out
running around in twirling circles in
the yard or whatever yes is that reality
right now no
so don't Rob from him
hit what he committed to do and walk
around with this just shame all the time
okay you are lucky to have somebody in
your life who said I'm all in on you you
all share these debts and so together
y'all owe twenty seven thousand dollars
yes
no other debt that's it
no that's right what is the car worth if
you if you sold it today let's say in
the private Marketplace what could you
get for it
um I am unsure of that because I've not
looked into that it's a 2018 Kia Optima
okay that's your next homework
assignment because if you can sell this
thing okay and get a cheap car that gets
you around from A to B well that clears
that 17 right there
um hopefully you have enough cash to pay
for the next one if you can make a
little profit off it how much do you
guys have in the bank do you have any
savings
no zero dollars exhausted all everything
crap okay let's get a thousand bucks in
the bank as quickly as possible and that
might mean your husband needs to take a
side hustle for a short season so that
we can clean up this mess but that will
then get you down to just the credit
cards 10K he's making 70. we clear up
the credit card debt well then we could
breathe a little bit right even on one
income we could pay all of our bills
correct and so that would be my next
goal because we know what's hurting so
so much is the rent and the car payment
together that's right and here's the
deal your life is different now and what
I I this happens all the time a major
life incident happens somebody passes
away somebody gets sick there's a a job
loss and people want to continue with
their life as it is
and
just try to incorporate this new this
this major life shift into their
existing life you have to own reality
your life is different so maybe you got
to move you got to downsize maybe you
got to move to a different town maybe I
gotta move to a completely different
state and Community where you can afford
to rent and make a little bit more money
you'll have to start there with real
real numbers and face reality head-on
yeah the sooner you can become debt free
with a pile of money in the bank the
sooner you have Financial Peace and then
we can learn to live in this new reality
with one income that puts this hour of
the Ramsay show in the books my thanks
to my co-host Dr John deloney all the
guys in the booth keeping the show alive
and you America we would not do the show
without our amazing listeners we'll be
back with you before you know it
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18 mil
radio stations
station the station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality George
Campbell joined this hour by Jade
warshaw for the very first time our
newest Ramsay personality we are so
excited to have her on the team if
you've been listening to the show for
more than like seven seconds you know
Jade's voice she was on the show with
Dave in the past few weeks just hearing
your story you're starting to take calls
how's it been George you're too kind
you're too kind you know what's felt
good this has really been like a long
time coming but at the same time
something that I I never imagined you
know I told everybody before before this
I was in entertainment so I you know
money was just uh it was learning how to
manage money had changed our lives but
really helping others was really just a
hobby so here we are yeah we joked about
it the other day that we were always
long time fans of the Ramsay show both
you and I and now we're inside of it and
it's like it's the honor of a lifetime
and you're like oh gosh we're in this
thing we're in the matrix it's crazy it
is crazy we are in The Matrix and I have
to admit I've actually never seen that
movie it's fine we'll watch it together
at some point I probably could use a
refresher but you have an incredible
story give people like the quick
snapshot of what you and your husband
Sam accomplished okay quick snapshot is
this pick
one week after college graduation right
you get married to your college
sweetheart and you're just hoping for
your happily ever after and about I
don't know about a year into it you
realize this this is not a dream George
this is this is a nightmare you've got
up to four hundred and sixty thousand
dollars of debt now I'll be honest at
that point it wasn't quite that much but
by the time we started paying it and
with the interest that accrued four
hundred and sixty thousand dollars of
debt that is suspiciously close Millions
yes oh my goodness half a million can't
breathe no you can't breathe uh you're
suffocated and you are you're you're not
happy I could tell you that George and
um Sam and I we just looked at things
and we're like hey like we've always
been the type to talk and you know dream
together and at one point it was like if
we want to accomplish any of the things
that we say we want even just base level
we have to change this we have to pay
off this debt and so um I remember Dave
uh from being in my brother's car Dave
was on the radio and uh I remembered I
was like I remember this guy talking
about money Dave Ramsey let's go get the
book and then from there on it was just
game on it was like let's work these
baby steps and I can tell you guys right
now the baby steps work if you work them
you got to work them in order you can't
be Dave ish because trust me me we tried
that a little bit we tried to hang on to
the credit cards a little too long and
it just puts you backwards you have to
follow the steps if you follow the steps
George it works the plan works if you
work at seven and a half years later
we're screaming I'm dead Freedom that's
incredible and you guys did your debt
free scream on the show and our old
building yeah uh which was incredible
and here you are today on the show
helping other folks get out of debt
helping them realize that it's possible
oh it's possible belief and especially
those that have a big pile of debt and a
long journey ahead of them it may not be
18 months for them and maybe seven years
that's right and that's why I started
thinking about the idea you might have
heard Dave mentioned at six figure
Freedom Club it's about those folks
who've got six figures of more debt
right and maybe you're maybe your
process is longer than average because
we say that the average person gets out
of debt and you know 24 to 36 months
right but that's not always the case
with everybody I'm a person who was not
average and for this reason it was in a
bad way so it took us a little bit
longer but it can still be done and if
you're listening out there and you've
been in it three years four years and
maybe you've got three or four years
more to go you can do it stay the course
man keep working it will pay off it will
pay off I love it well we're so excited
to have you on the team you've got an
infectious energy and passion and you
are so wise and let's put it to the test
you ready to take some calls all right
George let's go let's go triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number to call you jump in we'll talk
life and money Meredith is in NYC
Meredith welcome to the show
um hello thank you for taking my call
um hi
um I I have a question um I I'm 66 years
old
I have some money in my Vanguard account
and a correct account and I'm wondering
if it is worth it to do a Roth
conversion if let's say I quit my job in
a couple of years how much money are we
talking
in my Vanguard account I have
and in my craft accounts I have about
175 175
000.
um oh you have more keep go keep going
you got more no that's it that's all I
got and that's is that all of your
retirement
that's your nest egg
yes okay and what's causing you to want
to convert all this to Roth
what about all of it uh the the amount
that needs to be converted is about 500
000. okay I have about maybe a hundred
and some of it is in Ross already the
reason is you know I realized that
eventually I was going to have to pay
taxes on that money right uh that was
tax deferred however what I didn't
realize it was I was gonna have to pay
taxes on my this
pay off pay taxes online about 500 000
of my Ross do you see your income do you
see your income going up when you retire
or do you think is it going to stay the
same
like what you plan to draw what the what
the rmd is going to be I don't know what
I'm going to have to
withdrawal I'm not quite sure what I'm
going to have to withdraw because at 72
you have to withdraw a certain amount if
it's not all converted and that's
another thing I I don't want to have to
be forced to withdraw
well you're going to take some money out
right to live correct correct and and
and but I don't want to have to be
forced to withdraw a certain amount I
can understand that especially and even
if you plan on leaving some of this
money you know to your heirs that's also
a nice gift in estate planning to make
sure that you've got you know they're
not having to pay the taxes on on
withdrawing it and also you know that
you're just getting them the maximum
bang for your buck there so there are
definitely some good reasons
um if George what do you think I I think
it's definitely worth it to convert some
of that money over yeah are you do you
have a paid for house and no Consumer
Debt
well my house is paid for I owe about
four thousand dollars more on my car
it's a 2019. I owe
um I owe about ten thousand dollars in
my I have one credit card and a lot of
that has been towards my house I had to
have things I had to have a new septic
and and things like that that I have to
pay for so that was for the house mostly
do you have some liquid cash on hand
that you could clear that debt out
because the way we teach it I think
George what you're getting at is making
sure you're at the correct place in the
baby steps so we want to make sure that
you're I mean obviously you're a
millionaire but we want to make sure
that everything before that point is in
place so we want to make sure that
you've got three to six you know number
two we want to make sure you've paid off
all of your debt and then after that we
want to make sure that you have three to
six months of of cash savings or liquid
savings that you can get to and of
course working on up you know you're
you're almost uh to that point but we
just want to make sure everything is in
order yeah the only time we would tell
anyone to convert regardless of their
age is one certain baby step seven which
is no Consumer Debt fully funded
emergency fund house is paid off and
you're real close Meredith and before
you do that I would still it doesn't
sound like you have a good financial
advisor in your life I would get
connected with a smartvester pro
ramseysolutions.com who can crunch the
numbers for you and show you what both
pictures look like down the road because
at your age they may say hey it's
actually not worth it to convert for
these reasons so it's good I don't want
to steer you wrong in a one minute phone
call here so get connected to
ramseysolutions.com and congratulations
on being a millionaire
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel Join This Hour by our
newest Ramsay personality Jade warshaw
and we're taking your calls at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
friendly reminder that if you enjoy the
show you appreciate what we do reminder
that this show is free and so here's
what we ask of you and it's also free
consider subscribing following and
leaving us a five star review if you
love the show and share it with a friend
it's hard to get a new podcast a new
show into someone's life unless it's a
friend saying Jake you gotta check out
the show oh yeah is it worth it you go
yeah yeah and people are always looking
for some new content to to consume
especially helpful content right in a
world that's just noise yes George so
some people love the show so much that
they email in and sometimes it's not
love Jade sometimes they have they've
got bones to pick they go oh man peers
that are have been grinded and uh
producer James sent us one that David
sent in so can I read it out loud read
it out loud with feeling
thanks for all the entertainment and
advice regarding finances but what I
don't get is why you guys get all
excited when a guy says I just got
engaged or I just got married there's
hand clapping cheers congrats Etc
especially when it's someone in their
early 20s these kids are just too young
to know what they're getting into but
you guys cheer them on unreal fact is
that guy just signed a contract saying
if the marriage doesn't work out which
most don't then there's a good chance
she'll take them to the cleaners and
divorce court we hear about this all the
time there is nothing in it for guys to
get married at all this did not happen
to me I am not married so I am not
bitter or angry women can usually cash
in if it doesn't work out people might
argue that getting married is good
because you have a partner someone to
help you Etc but you can have all of
that without signing a contract saying
you will provide cash and prizes alimony
and or child support when it doesn't
work out in California if you get
divorced after 10 years you will be
paying her forever or until she
remarries I've noticed that in most
marriages soon after the vows the woman
chunks up chops off most of her hair and
starts barking orders at her husband oh
marriage is not like it was 50 years ago
would love to hear what you think thank
you wow David so much to unpack there
and I think you a professional counselor
should do it but you know we'll add some
color commentary to this my guy my guy
sounds like he's been burned George or
absolutely he's jaded one of the two
like wow yeah which you know what as
much as we can pick on David he
represents a large portion of the the
male population who feels this way and
if you don't believe me go to any
YouTube comment section and they're in
there going this is why you should never
get married they'll take you to the
cleaners that's interesting because
there's actually so many great I mean
this is a show about money your life and
your money but there's actually a lot of
great reasons to be married I mean if we
talk about it from the money standpoint
I mean he seems to think that you know
it's it's all about being taken to the
cleaners and it's all about lose using
out I mean I definitely have some maybe
you're just picking the wrong lady but
you know there there are definitely some
some positives to being married after
being married 15 years I'd like to think
that there's
yeah I just never once looked at
marriage as this like Financial contract
and who's getting what like that's just
a weird way a weird Spirit to have well
no you definitely don't want to go into
it like that like hey I'm gonna marry
this guy simply because you know that
that you have that attitude and you get
married you probably will get divorced
and it'll be a self-fulfilling prophecy
oh yeah because you went in with
terrible intentions yeah terrible Spirit
side note that just made me think of a
story so my husband Sam who happens to
be sitting out there when we were
engaged he was in his grandfather's will
right to to get money upon death but
there was a a stipulation that said he
had to marry someone Jewish
to get the money and your girl well your
girl is not Jewish so that put us
ultimately to the test wow and Sam chose
me over over the world well how much how
much are we talking here like 10 million
or 20 grand seventy thousand dollars 70
grand you're worth more than 70. I like
to think it's it's great to know that
I'm worth it
but we know that you're at least worth
more than that 100 and I think he's
saying the ROI is there the Roi he would
do it all over again he better he's
amazing he better well Jay this is an
interesting conversation because there's
been a lot in the news yes about
marriage and wealth and the power of
couples to build wealth versus someone
who's single or even those that are
cohabitating yes you're shacking up yeah
so what are we finding you know it's
interesting I I read an article on the
Wall Street Journal and they were
talking about this wealth Gap that
you're talking about and they found that
people who were living together just
living together not married
um not even sharing their finances but
they had their net worth was a quarter
of those who were married and sharing
finances wow a quarter that means if
you're married sharing your finances you
are earning three quarters more your net
worth is that much higher yeah here's
here's the numbers if you're curious the
median this is as of 2019 median net
worth for cohabitating couples age 25 to
34 with 17 grand and for married couples
it was 68 Grand and for singles Seven
Grand yeah that that
that is shocking shocking in some ways
but actually George when you really
think about it it's not that shocking
because think about it I'm just thinking
of it from compound interest alone I
mean compound interest on a one person's
say they've contributed ten thousand
dollars right and then the spouse over
here contributed another ten thousand
dollars compound interest isn't helping
you the same as if you had twenty
thousand dollars all in one spot so
there's that then there's a whole
homeowner side of it oh yeah you're more
likely to be a homeowner which is you
know houses appreciate and you're more
likely to be investing you're more
likely to have dual incomes and it's
harder to gain traction as a young
single person than it is as a married
couple and so better together and we
also there's new studies one is from uh
Cornell showing that joint bank accounts
have a higher correlation to longer
lasting and happier marriages that is
very interesting that's a controversial
stance we have is that you should
combine bank accounts and people come at
us with the spirit of David saying oh my
she's gonna take you to the cleaners if
you I don't know why I'm becoming a
wrestler right now but that's the that's
the David voice it's interesting you
know there's got I think the connection
there is that you've you have long-term
planning in mind you've if you're
willing to to combine your finances it
means that hey there's a strong level of
trust which you know it takes trust to
really get anything done and then that
you're really thinking towards the
future you've sat down and you've
planned out which means you're probably
on the same page and you know as well as
I do that when when people when there
where there is no vision the people
perish Dave says it all the time you
know and and I think that when you have
that Vision as a couple as a married
couple you put your money together of
course you're going to go further faster
you're going to do better together yeah
and there's accountability that is built
in when you have a partner because when
you're single you can kind of just like
do your own thing and No One's Gonna
yell at you for going on a retail
therapy spree facts versus Sam going uh
hey I just saw that bank transaction
come through what's going on here let's
have a conversation about it and so that
accountability helps keep you on track
the shared Vision the shared goals and
it's one of the reasons Financial Peace
University is such a powerful tool oh
man change both of our lives and my
spouse works at Ramsey Solutions hey and
so when we started our marriage off I
had already gotten out of debt she was
way smarter than I was and never touched
debt and so we had this crazy goal of
like what if we saved up a huge down
payment and then paid off our house as
quickly as possible wow and so in 26
months we paid off our mortgage
after the intensity and we did our debt
free scream yes almost a year ago
and I'm telling you the power to build
wealth when you have a couple that's on
the same page with the same language
shared common language the same goals
shared Vision I mean that's what makes a
power couple Unstoppable Unstoppable you
guys are unstoppable so if you want that
it's available for you and don't listen
to The Hope Stealers out there like
David saying don't get married she's
going to take you to the cleaners
absolutely get rid of that turd attitude
right now okay have a little bit of hope
we need more optimists in this world and
there's plenty of amazing marriages out
there plenty of people who will show you
that it's possible and one of the
reasons is getting on the same page with
money that's right George and it begs to
be said because I gotta say this people
might be listening and going oh if we
just combine our finances that's that's
our golden ticket if y'all are out there
say you're living together but you're
not married do not combine your finances
if you're not married don't come by your
finances yes right we got to say that
because the implications there could be
dire put your ring on it go to the
courthouse and then combine your bank
accounts and by the way if you're one of
these guys that's been dating a girl for
like eight or nine years she's waiting
on the ring job man she's been waiting
too long homegirl's about to bounce if
you don't commit come on son so that's
just a PSA to all the Jeffs out there if
your name is Jeff and your good guy I'm
sorry but I just had to use someone's
name that's Jeff's good I usually like
Biff or
rarely is
my goodness what's a good good
conversation David we picked on you but
we do appreciate the email and thank you
for listening you can send in your
feedback at askit ramseysolutions.com
and uh more of the Ramsay show and color
commentary coming right up
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
we are back on the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by our
newest Ramsay personality Jade warshaw
and folks you've probably heard words
like inflation in layoffs in the economy
in the news lately and if you're a
little confused you're a little scared
about what all that means you're not
alone but the truth is you can't control
what's going on at the White House but
you can control what's going on at your
house so I want you to join me Dave
Ramsey Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney Ken
Coleman this spring in a city near you
for our Building Wealth tour we're going
to teach you the proven plan to
inflation proof your money build lasting
wealth and invest your money wisely and
we're kicking off Building Wealth in
Nashville Tennessee January 12th then we
are heading to Indianapolis February
16th
we're going to Austin Texas February
23rd we're going to Salt Lake City on
April 24th and ending the spring tour in
Anaheim California on May 2nd so if
you're near one of those places you can
make the flight make the drive we'd love
to have you general admission passes
start at just 49 bucks but do not wait
because all of our fall Building Wealth
events sold out real quick and these
will too get your event passed today at
ramseysolutions.com events that's
ramseysolutions.com events well the
number to call to join the conversation
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five Sam has decided to do that over
in San Antonio Sam welcome to the Ramsay
show
okay guys thank you for having me
absolutely what's going on
hey so I just got married last month
that's awesome
thank you and we'll plan to have a
family
um currently finishing maybe step three
and we'll put and we're looking at
health insurance plans or health plans
so yeah that's adulting right
yeah and we do not know how much to plan
for it or how much to budget for it we
know you guys back up uh Christian
Ministries but they have several prints
too and I don't know how to budget them
or which one to look for
is the insurance coming through your
employer and they just have several
options for you or are you self-employed
and you're kind of out there in the
market yourself
oh I'm in the market myself my boss does
not provide nothing for health you have
to pay it off out of pocket okay yeah I
mean I can I can attest to that uh Sam
and I were business owners for you know
a long time before we came here and we
had to pay we had to you know research
our own insurance and and find the plan
that worked for us I I would love if you
got connected with Xander
um because they can shop out all of the
different options for you and you can
choose the one that works best for you
um and you know without a whole lot of
information you know it really depends
on what you're looking for if both you
and your wife and everybody's healthy
then you can search for something that's
got a really high deductible so that you
know you're you're out of cost monthly
is is not quite so much and maybe
there's an HSA attached so you can plan
for future health you know concerns that
you might have to pay for out of pocket
but if you know if you think you're
going to be going to the doctor all the
time and things like that then you might
look for something that's got you know a
lower deductible so it really just it
depends on what's going on with your
health situation and have you shopped
any yet
yes and there are around 500 to a
thousand dollars is that for the whole
family they should do around four
percent of your income but four percent
of my income is around three hundred
dollars a month I wouldn't worry about
percentages of that either when you're
especially when you're self-employed and
you're going out in the marketplace
yourself the numbers are going to be
higher which is not fun to deal with but
it's a part of of this journey you're on
since your employer doesn't cover it and
it may be beneficial long term if you're
like hey I might find a different
employer that does have health insurance
either subsidized or covered that may be
worth it for some people it's a big
benefit that people look for when it
comes to employment so that's something
to look out for in the future but for
now like Jade was saying if the family's
healthy it's kind of the extremes I
would be looking at the high deductible
health plan if you've got a real healthy
family or if there's a ton of health
issues where you're going to the doctor
a lot because you will max out the
deductible quickly and then they'll
cover a hundred percent after that yeah
anywhere in between you might want to
look into the the PPO preferred provider
organization station so that's kind of
the way to look at it and again it
depends on how much risk you're willing
to take on versus the insurance company
and the more risk you're willing to take
on with that high deductible the less
you'll pay in that monthly premium and
so the good news is you guys are almost
through baby step three right
yes I'm going to finish next week I love
it that puts you guys in a very
different place it gives you Financial
Peace when you don't owe anyone anything
you've got the margin to cash flow a lot
of these medical expenses you can take
the hit on the full deductible if
something happened and so that's what I
would be more concerned about do I have
the money to cover the full deductible
until they would pay a hundred percent
and if you've got that you're in good
shape that's so good how about burning
pyro for all medical expenses I want to
hopefully it never happens but with time
putting like little by little and
waiting for nothing to happen I missed
that what was the first part
putting like a little money apart and
just saving it and saving it just in
case it gets you need use it in the
future yes and that's where the the HSA
if you get a high deductible health care
plan it will be attached with an HSA
health savings account and so you can
contribute money there are limits in
there but it's thousands and thousands
of dollars each year you can put in
there and can use that towards qualified
medical expenses and it's got some great
tax benefits because the money goes in
tax-free it grows tax-free and you can
withdraw the money tax-free and it has
an investing vehicle as well once you
get past a certain threshold in the
account you can actually invest that
money into mutual funds and have that
money grow for you so it's there's some
really great options so I'm a huge fan
of the HD HP with the HSA so many
acronyms so little time but that's what
I would be looking into Sam to kind of
start your homework off but I love that
you're thinking about this stuff
okay nobody helps me a lot thank you
guys yeah man in your opinion yeah head
to ramseysolutions.com and click on
Ramsay recommends you can get in touch
with our uh trusted providers over there
to figure this stuff out juicy
conversation Jade I love the HD HP
multiple health plan right oh man so
many acronyms so many all right let's
move on to something non-healthcare
related maybe we'll see Dave is in Tulsa
Oklahoma Dave welcome to the show
hey George hey Jade how are you guys
we're doing great how can we help
uh well so I'm giving my situation real
quick my wife and I
um sold our home and moved in with our
sister-in-law in the meantime to try to
buy more land and build or find a house
that has more land
um in the meantime we just found out a
few weeks ago that we are having twins
yeah very excited uh and I feel like the
the pressure's on a little bit more yeah
it is to get us moved into something
um so the situation is we might be
buying anywhere from 7 to 13 acres for
115 of over 200 000
um and I'm thinking well maybe we buy
less land and build something small
because we have a dream home in mind we
know what the price is on that and it's
pretty much at the top of our budget
um or do we just try to buy all the land
and then go buy a home that's already
built and you know wait four or five
years I don't have any kids this will be
my my first two
um knocking two out at once just trying
to figure out
do I just need to go ahead and get in a
home or
should I kick it with the in-laws for a
little bit and build our dream home in
four years I mean I for sure want an
exit strategy to to be on your own
whether that's renting buying building
whatever you do I want to have a clear
plan on what this looks like so there's
no resentment and weird relational
situations how much money do you guys
have safe like are you out of debt fully
funded emergency fund plus the down
payment
absolutely we are I've been a Dave
Ramsey fan for probably the last five
years now my wife's fully on board we've
got 130 000 in cash no debt
um nice we're ready to do something I
just we I can't figure out what we
should do you know Dave you've got a lot
going on you're living with the
sister-in-law you you've got twins on
the way you're thinking about buying
land buy land with a house buy land and
build a house buy land and build a
different you know there's a lot going
on I think as much as you can simplify I
think that's that's the choice that I'm
going towards and I don't know what that
means for you in my mind I'm thinking
okay let me see if we're simplifying
we're just trying to get out of the
sister-in-law's house if we've got money
to put a down payment on a existing home
that we love and that serves the purpose
I might Veer towards that the land that
you're looking at buying is it does it
hold any sentimental value like is it
family related or is it just a a plot
that you saw and you thought
it does it is pretty close to my well
some of it is my wife's old family land
okay
um and then the rest of it would be you
know her uncles or cousins whatever and
we are wanting to build there
um but there's also a home that just
popped up not too far down the road
within our budget if you can snatch up
some of that land maybe snatch up some
land and if you have enough to that
would be cool split the difference there
yeah yeah but it sounds like you you
might need to delay the dream of the
land because we got we got kids coming
to the picture we gotta have somewhere
to live we got to get out of the
sister-in-law's house okay so I might
just jump on a house that's available
right now and the land and building can
come later right now it's time to be a
dad day congratulations man
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show our scripture of
the day comes from John 16 33. I have
said these things to you that in me you
may have peace in the world you will
have tribulation but take heart I have
overcome the world
Edwin LeFevre said Being Broke is a very
efficient educational agency that's a
nice way that's I like that framing of
it I like it's a little more positive
it's the School of Hard Knocks and
teaching moments that's right we love it
well I'm George Campbell Join This Hour
by our newest personality Jade warshaw
you may have heard her on the Ramsey
show a few times hanging out with Dave
Ramsey but today is our first time
co-hosting together and it's been a real
Joy it's a momentous occasion George we
just took a selfie to commemorate we did
that's how Millennial we are we're still
hip we're still with it am I am I
considered a millennial I don't know
let's not tell the people oh boy I might
be on the well you know you haven't aged
a day since I've known you
all right open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Allen
joins us in Charlotte North Carolina
Alan welcome to the show
hey thank you very much how you doing
George we are doing great how can we
help today
um I kind of have a dilemma here my wife
and I have been going back and forth on
it for probably the last three weeks
um we're baby stuff seven I'll stayed
off obviously no debt love it Randy
Randy's show about a year ago with
baloney and Ramsay that's awesome doing
your dad free scream
yeah it's still debt-free today
those cookies are very good by the way
we gotta treat you well oh yeah
so here's the math I know Dave always
says math doesn't lie and I appreciate
that
um but our house is paid off it's worth
around a half a million
we're looking to buy a lake house that
we're supposed to close on on December
29th right after Christmas wow my wife
and I have been going back and forth
trying to decide whether we should just
stay in a paid off house for the
debt-free life maybe step seven
or roll the dice
what is rolling the dice that's what I
want to know
the roll the dice is to take on a
mortgage again and go back to baby step
six and with these interest rates these
days with the FED
um we're looking at 6.385 and that's
with you know no debt and I know credit
scores don't matter but we have 800
credit no debt so are you saying you
would sell your primary residence and
then buy this lake house and just move
there
yes and as better schools in that town
and it's something my wife really wants
um we're open to the option of renting
out the current house that we live in
that's gorgeous or rent to own or
selling but the house we're purchasing
is around 725
000. oh wow so you don't have the cash
to do this deal
we make 200 000 a year
um we we can get around 45 to 500 000
for the current house that we have
that's paid off and I'm kind of just
looking for your blessing to move
forward with the lake house knowing that
this house is in contingent and we still
have to sell it which it's on the market
right now or should we just stay at baby
step seven and stay in this house and
just wait a little longer until we can
buy it when you get out of this deal
legally yes yeah because it basically
the cost is the uh due diligence okay
somewhere around seven Grand but we
could basically just walk away yeah man
I don't have peace about this lake house
deal because if you do stay in your
house you don't have the money for this
700 000 lake house
well right now isn't it contingent isn't
it contingent on the sale of his current
house is that what you mean when you
said it's
well what I mean is our house is a tray
is for around a half a million it's
listed right now to sell the house we're
buying is 725 000 but we don't have an
offer yet or any traffic in the current
house that we're living in and that
could be due to Christmas you know
people are not looking to purchase over
the holidays but we're thinking within
by January February we should have an
offer so if you're around a half a
million so if you if
I I think I'm with George
I wouldn't only do it if you can sell
your house and it's it's okay if you
want to go to baby step six temporarily
and pay off that mortgage quickly but I
wouldn't have two properties doing that
it's got to be contingent on the first
sale yeah which is tough and it might
slow down the process but it's also
going to give you a whole lot of Peace
oh yeah
because otherwise you're on the hook for
725 thousand dollars
right so if the house sells our mortgage
would be around 225 and we make around
200 000 a year combined sure and we're
desperate yeah and it's a it's a lake
house with the you know private boat
dock everything abuse whatever you can
picture for a lake house it's not to say
that you can't have the lake house we
just got to do it the right way and I
think that's what George is saying is we
want to make sure that you're at no
point trying to float two mortgages is
that right George yeah because right now
if this was an investment property we
would tell you to pay cash if you're
going to keep your primary but if you're
saying hey we're going to sell our
primary move into this one take on a
mortgage pay it off quickly you guys
make a great income I got no problem
with that but having both Properties
Plus having a mortgage on that one that
one doesn't give me peace so I would
slow down we are baby stuff seven and
the primary is paid off I understand but
if Dave Ramsey were on air can you tell
you that investment property that's a
toy and you're paying cash for that
that's the only way you're doing it and
so as long as you're hanging on to the
prime primary it's not really that kind
of situation
so if we sold the primary and and
profited 500 000 liquid to put towards
the 725. that is the only way I do this
year
are we good to buy sales for the 225
000. go back to maybe step six yes and
guess what within a few years that
thing's paid off how old are you guys
I'm 43 and my wife's 33. oh that's
incredible you guys are killing it
you're crushing it so I think we just
need to be patient it sounds like we got
real excited about the lake house idea
and I just don't want you to sidestep
some things and step into a stressful
situation when you're trying to sell the
house and I might just pause and go all
right we're going to wait until uh 2023
and do this the right way or make it
contingent on the sale of our house and
that might slow things down I agree I
agree appreciate the uh call Alan good
conversation congratulations on baby
step seven those are the kinds of
problems you get to have by following oh
yeah but you know what I think I think a
lot of people get to that point George
where maybe they have paid off a
mortgage and they're ready to move up
and once you're totally debt free no
debt in the world it's it's tough
mentally I think to go back to the idea
of having a mortgage even in his case if
it was only going to be I think he said
125 or something like that he's going to
knock it out in four years or you know
less but I think that's hard to kind of
go oh am I going to take on a mortgage
again or am I going to just sit pretty
where I'm at so you know either way was
fine but yeah and I understand it's a
controversial very conservative
Financial stance to say only by
investment property with cash because if
you have watched Tick Tock for more than
four seconds there's all these get rich
quick real estate gurus telling you to
do the bur method and you need to buy
with nothing down and then you can
refinance that because the house
appreciated and you get the HELOC and
nope and you're just playing all these
crazy games and it's very risky very and
I just want to sleep better at night the
blessing of the Lord makes rich and adds
no sorrow Oh George Jade just dropping
those mic drop verses that's what they
say you know and like you said I think
sometimes you just got to take a cold
shower you know you just gotta cool the
emotions down because I think we've all
been there and I'm not saying that this
is where he was but you know you get you
get emotional about something and you
you rush into it and before you know you
have a little bit of remorse you don't
feel that peace so well I'll drop
another one on you wealth gained hastily
will dwindle but whoever got others
little by little will increase it bars
so take that get rich quick crypto Bros
look at them now Jade I mean I'm not
happy about it they're shooting and
they're snikies not gloating in it but
as much crap as we got from the crypto
Bros you guys don't understand the
blockchains the future you particularly
oh yeah you were on the front line
because I did an episode on the fine
print about crypto and uh it wasn't it
wasn't pretty it was like Hey if you
want to play with crypto that's fine but
a lot of these get rich quick from Real
Estate to crypto there's so much risk
there's so much greed people like the in
your brain the part of your brain that's
like hey safety is important that goes
out the window absolutely and people
make terrible decisions and I just want
to save people from Financial harm
that's the heart of it it's not that I'm
trying to hate on something new because
I'm oh yeah I have a you know Boomer
brain or something I'm I'm young and I'm
hip I just also know that the tried and
true methods of gods and Grandma's ways
of handling money always works in good
time and in bad George you're preaching
your preach and if that makes me an old
curmudgeon so be it an old curmudgeon
yeah just the word curmudgeon makes me a
commercial
gosh unbelievable well hey Jade it's
been a fun hour appreciate you uh being
on the team excited to co-host more and
more with you she's fantastic you can
check her out at Jade warshaw on
Instagram appreciate all the folks in
the booth Austin James Zach Andrew
they're keeping the show afloat America
and you are too thank you so much for
listening leave us a review share this
with a friend we want to spread this
impact spread the hope to all of America
we'll be back soon on the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]